I want you all to be bhuvan's okay LaVon
is a girl's name you need to shut the
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what the hell hey camera B camera can
you deal with this you don't call
[ __ ] people retards it's bad taste
you call your friends retards here's
your headline Scranton paper company
Dunder Mifflin apologizes to valued
client some companies still know how
business over the gums and through the
lips look out stomach there we go my
uncle Harvey Schrute is a fudge packer
he works at the Hershey factory now I
know what you're thinking won't that
just shed more light on the penises but
you know what that's what
that is that is a risk that we have to
none at all no what you're saying you
keep going hey I know what you're
thinking won't that just [ __ ]
I know what you're thinking won't that
just shed more light on the penises but
that is a risk we need to take Pam Thank
You Pam what did you work with phallus
picture of the buzzer I want it on my
desk by the end of the day or you will
receive a full desaturation what's that
we had a funeral for a bird I'm pretty
sure no no that's real
you're not real huh we've any muffins
yeah
take a longer pause before you answer
Pam I don't know if you like country
music but I was thinking maybe one of
these days god bless america would you
please sign my company directory I'm
about people who is that I don't mean to
be crass but get prepared to get wet I'm
sorry
hey holdin up pretty good Paul what's up
oh I have so much to tell you yeah Tom
Cruise and Katie Holmes they had a baby
and they named it Shiloh and Brad Pitt
and Angelina they had a baby too and
they named it Surrey I think you have
those mixed up this chick is a dude or
Halpert what got scared straight got
lines come on Hector all right I'm the
I'm the Candyman Santa's come early sure
Santa Santa would like to be real Santa
would like to buy you a pair of panties
little girl
[Laughter]
I'm hurt when he came out for soccer
practice I pinched him where did you
pinch him where would you like the rice
krispies treat stars there Sugar Plum
Fairy ones Sugar Plum Fairy one sugar
[Music]
phyllis yogurt container phyllis yogurt
container naturally he hopes he can
count on your discretion
well it's all y'all I want to know what
I was in for
no no so you all want to know what now
I locked it
this is totally this is totally okay
[Laughter]
Jimbo last chance to carpool you wanna
carpool carpool together we're severly
Terrell huh carpool together I'm either
sabotage what are you saying are you
saying sandwich no I was saying that
before are you okay sorry I mean we
laugh so hard you say it sabotage
okay I got it now I got it
sabotage hey hey what's different about
you you look worse thank you you got a
haircut talk me through an appendectomy
step one disinfect step two incision
step three locate the source of the
infection
step three tenderly remove the appendix
so is not because we have been driving
the wrong way Pam Beesly or like Pam
Babli
[Laughter]
you